hey everybody thanks so much for coming
it's wonderful to see you here this
special evening with Ann Coulter sorry
for the slight delay in timing there's
as you know relocation from the Nixon
Library here because of the size of the
venue and so we wanted to make sure that
anybody who mistakenly went over the
Nixon Library got a map and got over
here and believe it or not there have
been a fair number of people who have
done that so we're giving it a little
bit of extra time in the meantime you're
gonna have to listen to me talk a little
bit because they pay me for that and you
don't so so want to ask let's do a quick
straw poll because those are fun and
useless so let's go through a few
candidates okay how many hands for Jeb
Bush he can be honest who won't stone
you it'll be all right
nobody's that brave okay okay let's see
let's see the hands for Ted Cruz okay
looks like about a quarter of the
audience
okay how about Donald Trump
[Applause]
okay and I'll give you two more
candidates and I promise you we won't go
all the way down the list because then
we'll be 10 o'clock at night before we
actually get here I'm not going to ask
about Jim Gilmore so okay how about
Marco Rubio okay their number for Rubio
and and Scott Walker who announced today
very interesting very interesting
there's a big crowd for Scott Walker
Walker obviously announces today but it
seems to me that obviously an odd amount
of enthusiasm for Donald Trump and it's
it's odd in one sense and it's obviously
not odd in another it's out in the sense
that Donald Trump is by no measure a
conservative if you look at his record
if you look at his record historically
he's not a conservative
Donald's from two years ago was
criticizing Mitt Romney for being too
conservative on immigration he was
saying there needed to be a pathway to
citizenship Donald Trump a few years
back was a pro-choice guy now he is
flipped and he's become a pro-life guy
Donald Trump we still don't know where
he is on same-sex marriage
Donald Trump has proposed not just an
income tax he's actually proposed a
wealth tax which would mean that if he a
14% wealth tax which means all of your
assets 14% would be gone so if you have
real estate holdings you would actually
have to liquidate your real estate
holdings in order to pay his wealth tax
so Donald Trump is not a conservative
but there's this big outpouring of
support for Donald Trump and the reason
that there's this big outpouring of
support for Donald Trump is two reasons
both of them are good one is better than
the other
the first reason which is not so great
is because Donald Trump has been smacked
by the left and the way we on the right
work is when somebody gets smacked by
the left we immediately go to okay this
must be the greatest person who ever
lived
which explains both the love for Donald
Trump and the and the continuing love
for Sarah Palin Palin says a lot of good
things she really does but there's this
kind of outside support for Sarah Palin
largely because she was so unfairly
attacked and maligned by the media which
I think everybody agrees with and so
everybody went okay we're with Sarah
because the media hates her so much
that's an okay reason it's not like a
really spectacular reason the real
reason why people support Donald Trump
the real reason why people support
Donald Trump is because he is capturing
the moral narrative in the country right
now because when you watch Scott Walker
and I don't know how many folks here
actually listen to or watch scott
Walker's announcement today
show of hands anyone who actually saw
okay so if you
yeah fair number of people saw it if you
watch I watch Scott Walker's
announcement today and when I watch
Scott Walker's announcement today was
very nice and it was all this stuff
about his record and how he had broken
the unions and how he had a vision for
the country and how he was going to take
on foreign policy very nice some speech
he delivered it as well as Scott Walker
can which is says it was articulate he's
not a very fiery guy so it's pretty
even-keeled delivery and he's it without
notes I mean it was it was impressive in
that sense a 45-minute speech without
notes unlike Trump without notes who's
actually coherent and actually had a
linear structure to it and but there was
one problem with what Scott Walker did
you could tell the problem with what
Scott Walker did when you listen to
Hillary's speech this morning Hillary
gave his speech in New York at the news
school and in this speech which is all
about her economic plans Hillary Clinton
dropped one line about Scott Walker she
only dropped one line about Scott Walker
she dropped one about Rubio one about
Bush and one about walker those are the
three she considers to be the
frontrunner and her line about Walker
was kind of interesting she said Scott
Walker wants to I believe that the word
that she that she used was something
like squashed the union's stomp thank
you a spoof stomped the Union exactly
she's the word stomp and then she
suggested that it was mean-spirited
right that was her that was her whole
appeal and it was in her speech was
about 40 minutes long and full of all
these very obscure policy proposals
about the continuing about continuing
interest rates on income tax all the
stuff that nobody cares about has ever
heard of the Buffett Rule which nobody
understands or cares about and but the
only thing that that was designed to do
was to elicit an emotional fear response
in people who are members of the left
that's what it was designed to do and
this is what the entire left does right
this is what the entire left does about
Trump for example right they say Donald
Trump hates Hispanics Donald Trump hates
Latinos and thus Donald Trump wants to
hurt you right this is what the
Confederate flag debate was about the
cannon who cares about the Confederate
flag no one cares about the Confederate
flag it hasn't been relevant in the
country for at least 50 years and before
that for a hundred years
I mean this the South lost the civil war
news bulletin
and the fact that this became a massive
cause celeb among luck that's because
what the left was attempting to do and
it's very clever is white guy white
racist shoots nine black people in
Charleston the entire country says this
is evil white people should not shoot
black people because it's racist and
evil and there's tremendous outpouring
of support
everybody is unified and the left goes
we can't have that because if people
realize that Americans actually get
along with each other that we're
actually nice people and we don't need
the government to cau us into submission
about all of this
then we won't vote for the left so
somehow they have to find a way of
dividing people and so the way that they
divide people is specifically by going
out of their way to find causes that
they can then blame on people so they
couldn't go with he's a Republican
because he wasn't Dylann storm roof so
instead they went with he liked
Confederate flags
that's not very strong so what they went
with after that was he likes Confederate
flags and a lot of Republicans like
Confederate flags there for Republicans
secretly believe like this guy and want
to shoot black folks right this is the
attenuated logic they use they use this
with Trump also Trump doesn't like
illegal immigration
thus he hates Latinos and wants to kill
as he knows well I promise you nothing
Donald Trump has ever said murdered a 32
year old woman in San Francisco and what
Donald Trump did that nobody else is
picking up on and this is something
Republicans should instead of just
shaming Trump and pretending that he's
unimportant well Republicans should do
and I'll conclude with this and then
we'll bring in over and get to the real
star of the show but what we really what
we're Republicans need to do is
recognize that what Trump does and what
he is so incredibly effective at in his
own kind of brusque and rough way is
Donald Trump says there is a villain to
this story there's a villain to this
story and we have to face down the
villain to this story there are bad guys
and there are good guys and you can
either be on the side of the bad guys or
you can be on the side of the good guys
and by doing that he channel's the anger
that everybody feels where we feel like
yes there are bad guys and there are
good guys we're not all well-meaning
people who just want what's best for the
country there are people in the country
who want what's worse for the country
and because Trump says that he generates
a lot of sympathy for himself and all
the other Republicans don't have to
agree with Donald Trump on anything or
everything but what they should do is
they should recognize the power of what
Trump is doing and the power of
narrative in the battle and they should
pick up on that and they should use it
to their best advantage now Anne's gonna
come over and and then we'll get started
so just a few more minutes and we'll be
ready to go thanks so much
[Applause]
so you guys ready to go alright and here
I'd like to bring back up in big round
of applause for Ben Farrell pulling up
here Ben
and without further ado let's please
give a nice Orange County welcome to
miss Ann Coulter
[Applause]
so this will be a rarity I've both read
the book and we can have a substantive
talk about it so that will be unusual
for me so why don't we jump right in
because I know that people have their
own questions that they want to ask as
well so obviously when I start with the
question that my that my co-host asked
you just the other week I'll strangle
you like I tried no host asks you about
the title of your book because we're
gonna have to but your titles so
productive provocative yeah that's what
you do you try to get people to read
your books and I'm thinking an
interesting title works better than in
fact I keep wanting to email
Thomas Sol one of my heroes and tell him
you gotta let me come up with the titles
for your books in my favorite writer but
this you know basic economics well the
reason that I think that people are
reacting to the book obviously is is
because there weren't sort of a catch-22
and I want you to address this and that
is that the Left refuses to talk about
this topic until someone says something
inflammatory at which point they won't
stop just yelling that people are saying
inflammatory things instead of talking
about the topic right it's very common
so how exactly do we break through that
well I think it's a worse catch-22 than
that I mean we're in a pincer movement
if it were just the American people
against the Democratic Party we would
win if it were just Americans against
the media we could win but it's the
American people against the Democrats
against the businesses against the
Republicans I mean just to get this
topic immigration talked about a it's
it's nearly impossible and I think
people don't realize how much the media
sets the agenda of what you even think
about we could go out to a bar right now
and ask people what's your position on
what happened in Ferguson what's your
position on gay marriage what's your
position on on global warming they've
all developed positions they've thought
about it immigration well I guess you
folks in California have thought about
it
but monistic how much the media
determines these are the items were
allowed to talk about on today's menu
and no you may not choose any items off
the menu which is why although
apparently I called him a clown a few
years ago I am so happy to see Donald
Trump in the race because wow he's
changed the agenda we're talking about
immigration now they're lying about
immigration but that's that's better
than not talking about it at all so
speaking of Donald Trump obviously he's
gone
you know he's had a big jump in the
polls you don't back Donald Trump for
president oh I totally do oh really yeah
he got an advance copy of my book he
obviously read an advance copy of my
book and he said that at a private
meeting Friday night he was very
generous he said his it was funny said
his sister always tells him you've
written more books than you've read
Donald and he told a crowd about this
sighs but I read out of you some Erika
and all of you should too so I thank
them for that I wish he'd mentioned it
more on TV because I really think it
would help him I want people to read my
book I'm one of the few authors who
writes her own books I believe I am the
only author who researches her own books
and and it's shorter than it looks it's
fun the shop chapters are short and when
you get toward the end they're even
shorter they're 120 pages of footnotes
oh it's way shorter than it looks and
you can totally read this book so please
read the book it is written in language
folks that even Democrats can understand
so let's start from the very beginning
you say that this is the greatest threat
facing America and I think this is a
hard sell for a lot of even Republican
haters those who have been told that
Isis is the greatest federal Russia is
the greatest threat or taxation or
social policy why is immigration the
greatest threat facing the country well
first of all I'm assuming a lot of you
are Republicans or conservative
Democrats and it just it feels like we
have been overwhelmed with wave after
wave of loss Obama is elected Obama is
reelected there is Obama care being
upheld twice by the Supreme Court game
mayor
voiced on us Obama withdraws our troops
from Iraq I am a ferocious supporter of
the Iraq war and I can't believe Obama
comes in and gives away our victory I
mean I hate him for that more than I
hate him for Obamacare none of this had
to happen it is all the result of Teddy
Kennedy's 1965 immigration act without
the 1965 Immigration Act the post 1970
immigrants very different from the
pre-1970 immigrants so I don't want to
hear any weeping about your
grandfather's but we'll get back to that
the post 1970 immigrants are what got
Obama elected in the first place he
could not have been elected without the
post 1970 immigrants who have been
voting 8 to 2 for the Democrats without
without the 1965 Immigration Act Romney
would have won a bigger victory against
Obama than Reagan did against Carter in
1980 I think probably some of you were
as surprised as I was the day at 3:00
a.m.
election night huh I thought he was
gonna win that well get used to saying
that a lot more huh I thought we were
gonna win that election what happened to
that state how did we get Obamacare well
Al Franken was the 51st vote for
Obamacare
how did he win well he's he cheated but
he wouldn't have been within within
shouting distance of cheating but for
100,000 Somalis now living in Minnesota
who were instructed by the first Muslim
Congressman keith Ellison
you must all vote for Al Franken without
Obama as president we wouldn't have
Sonia Sotomayor we wouldn't on the
Supreme Court we wouldn't have Eleanor
Kagan on the Supreme Court all these
losses didn't have to happen so whatever
you think the most important issue is
it's not I mean even now I get this
sense and from talking to people you run
into Democrats and especially
working-class Democrats saying you know
I have had it this the Democrats have
gone too far this hysteria over you know
taking down Confederate soldiers and
changing the name of the Jefferson
monument and and the fake rape cases and
Obamacare and gay marriage that's it I'm
voting Republican Hellfire will rain
down on these Democrats well
might well happen but Americans are
about to be over out voted by other
voters by foreign voters the Democrats
have brought in now that's only talking
about the political aspect because I'm
assuming this audience cares about the
political aspect and why should you care
about this issue more than anything else
certainly if you're a Republican but
it's more than that in order to bring in
voters who will vote 8 to 2 for the
Democrats we're bringing in extremely
primitive cultures and this is most of
what my book covers on - in order to
make it short and very readable 100
pages of footnotes is way shorter than
it looks
you got to read it III ended up cutting
200 pages a month before we went to
press but what I wanted to keep in and I
thought it was important to keep in were
gang rape child rape incest rape we are
bringing in peasant cultures it happens
the Latin America is the peasant culture
closest to us but that's not the only
one
Onoda these are very common behaviors as
our driving drunk and dumping your crap
on the ground I mean it is changing our
culture in ways that the rich don't
experience it's never coming to Nob Hill
in San Francisco it's probably not
coming to Newport Beach it's not coming
to Park Avenue know they just get the
cheap maids while Americans are the ones
bearing the cost not only in terms of
taxes in their schools being
overburdened in massive you know school
lunch programs the hospitals are going
bankrupt no it's ordinary Americans who
are paying the cost and most of all I
would add here are African Americans has
anybody in the media checked with or as
I've recently been instructed to stop
saying African Americans American blacks
because that is what I mean I'm not
talking about a guy whose father is a
Kenyan American blacks
[Music]
and they are the ones who are coming up
the socio-economic ladder who are just
getting a foothold who most of all whose
jobs are just being wiped out have you
seen the black teenage unemployment rate
well we have an obligation to our fellow
Americans and our fellow Hispanic
Americans who are also competing for
those low-wage jobs but the rich don't
care about that they want the cheap
labor they want you to pay for it and
they act like they're the ones speaking
for Lupe the maid well no you're not
speaking for Lupe the maid Lupe would
like her wage raised Lupe apparently
decided to immigrate to America and not
to Honduras or Pakistan Lupe wanted to
live in America I would like to live in
America but the elites don't they want
to live in Brazil where there is a very
very rich upper crust and the rest of us
are their servants and that is what
you're seeing you have seen since then
the deluge of these very peasant
cultures on America in order to give the
Democrats votes and and the rich cheap
labor you've seen a massive increase in
income inequality and which state has
the most income inequality you're in it
California which state has the least
income inequality Utah
one of the most monochromatic states so
you know liberals pretend they care
about income inequality they pretend
they care about the working class and
raising the minimum wage here's an idea
for raising the minimum wage stop
dumping low-wage workers on the country
then it will rise naturally through the
laws of supply and demand as it has in
Australia and New Zealand so there's a
lot there obviously
do you want the David Brooks you know
phobia question first or do you want the
sure David Brooks oh I'd be curious well
that that's why your smell sigh think
yeah I think that's exactly right David
Brooks his only audience are the actual
people at the New York Times who hire
David Brooks but David Brooks over the
weekend he suggested that Donald Trump
was was using textbook xenophobia in
order to drive out the vote and
suggested that any anti-immigrant
rhetoric essentially anti-illegal
immigrant rhetoric and talking about
different cultures that are not as good
as Western civilization would be
xenophobia how do you counter that or
have some people in the audience counter
that cuz we get this on a regular basis
obviously well I suppose I suppose if
you're only talking about people who
have no right to live here yeah you bet
arms you know opposed I'm not afraid of
them I think they're wrecking the
country but as I say they're wrecking
the country for the people already here
the racism question which I talk about a
lot in my book no no no no no the reason
Americans are sensitive to the race
issue particularly is because of the
legacy of slavery and Jim Crow that's
why that's why we have civil rights laws
that's why we have affirmative action
and set asides but then suddenly one day
out of the blue people used to talk
about integration all the time it was
integration you don't discriminate
against black people which we had to
spend a hundred years teaching the
Democrats not to do but that is all
about American blacks it's not about
someone who has never set foot in this
country before it's liberals who are the
racists who say oh you're all brown
we're gonna treat you like American
blacks and it's it's it's really kind of
shocking I mean I don't know if problem
maybe some of you know this Jesse
Jackson used to stand at the border
denouncing the illegal immigrants coming
across cesar chavez denounced them as
wetbacks driving down the wages of the
poor but today you can arrive from you
know the sudan yesterday you will get
affirmative action applying to college
you will get you will get affirmative
action applying for government business
loans one of one of the tricks
the cheap labor devotees pull when
talking about all the jobs being created
by immigrants at first I should start by
saying I've said this before whenever it
comes to immigration it is always like
the first line of Anna Karenina the
truth is always true in the same way the
lies are lies in their own ways so you
always have to look at the studies to
see what the lie is and one of the lies
about how immigrants create so many jobs
that's based on how many small business
loans they get from the federal
government will they get affirmative
action for that you're going to chase in
your tail here and by the way how many
businesses if those were successful but
as for xenophobia look David wasn't in
Brooks no I got him confused with Brock
look he and the rest of the Manhattan
elites and the farmers in need of cheap
labor refusing to mechanize no they'll
be in I mean it's there has to be a
restriction at some point there is
xenophobic the same way any country is
well how many people are there in the
world like five million they are getting
too close okay they don't like to live
here and collect welfare in America and
and you know have a nice life here but
we're not taking them all so at some
point liberals are cutting them off too
they will cut them off as soon as every
person they know who went to college or
at least one of the better colleges has
a maid a nanny a pool boy a gardener
once those needs are taken care of okay
that's it sorry Bangladesh you're not
coming in so I'm just saying how about
we cut it off to help Americans already
here now the people who live here now
so in your book you talk a lot about
also the demographics of winning in
terms of conservatism and you mentioned
earlier how a Romney would have
obviously won an overwhelming victory if
it hadn't been for the inundation of
people of different populations who've
been brought in by the 65 act let me ask
you from the Michael Medved perspective
because Michael takes the opposite
perspective and what he and I've had
this debate ourselves Michael will argue
that we have to do comprehensive
immigration reform we should be softer
on the border we should we should do all
of this in and we should bring in more
immigrants and find a pathway to
citizenship specifically because if we
don't do this then the Hispanic
population in the United States is the
fastest growing population even just
through natural growth and birth what do
we do in 20 30 years to win elections as
the white population of the United
States which historically votes
Republican decreases well a couple of
things I don't know how he could be any
softer on the border
perhaps we could fly them in directly
from Central America oh no I'm sorry
Obama is doing that no he's doing that
we are flying them in so they don't have
to go through that arduous journey
through Mexico handing him a voters
registration card point to I mean it is
certainly the case right now that if 71
percent of Hispanics had voted
Republican in the 2012 election Mitt
Romney still would have lost if four
percent more White's had voted
Republican Romney would have won and the
analogy not analogy but the point I
guess I make in my book is to California
in 1994 the demographics of the entire
country about are about what they were
in California in 1994 when Pete Wilson
won a huge come-from-behind victory by
tying himself with titanium chords to
Proposition 187 and anti-illegal
immigration measure would have cut
illegal immigrants off from getting any
government services that and to go back
to how mass immigration of low-skilled
workers not popular with with black
Americans Proposition 187 won a majority
of blacks of whites of Asians 30% of
Hispanics even people who were voting
for the Democrat were voting for
proposition 187
Pete Wilson got 20% of the black vote
that year across the country he got or
the average among congressional
Republicans was only 8%
so there's your path to victory
Republicans and then you've got to shut
it down because 0.3 well okay then
then we're just we're just I don't know
fiddling on the Titanic
because Hispanics don't care about about
amnesty they're in right they're already
in and of all the issues we're not gonna
win the Hispanics I also this idea this
idea that there's some sort of Hispanic
unity is something believed exclusively
by white liberals and the RNC apparently
I'm gonna talk to your maids once in a
while know the Dominicans hate the
Puerto Ricans the Mexicans hate the
blacks
there's no there is no unity here the
reason immigrants post 1970 have been
voting overwhelmingly for the Democrats
is because they're poor they're in need
of government services they come from
one-party states they are used to block
voting for a particular group I mean as
I say the People's Revolutionary Party
of Mexico ruled Mexico for 71 years just
you know tell me what tell me what the
symbol e is I have to go vote for and
I'll go do it the reason we have the
poor people voting for Democrats is
because that's what they do and it's not
just poor people I mean and it's not
just it's not just brown people look at
Piers Morgan if you want to see how
immigrants would vote and I'm by
definition any immigrant to America
makes America more statist and less free
because we are the freest country in the
world I mean it's like any immigrants of
Finland makes Finland less white this is
you know and when people move look at
poor Vermont it used to be rock-ribbed
Republican Vermont a bunch of New
Yorkers moved up there and now they have
Bernie Sanders as a senator a lot of
states is flat flipped when New Yorkers
have moved maybe shouldn't a fence
around New York
but the point is you always think and
yes there are some immigrants who are
coming and and and want to vote like
atomy as I say in the book who don't
need sixty years of seeing what the
Democrats do they understand them right
away they start voting Republican right
away glad to have you
that's twenty percent of them most of
them are bringing their their statist
politics with them and they have what
they're gonna get more benefits under
the democrats and they will under
republicans that is why they're voting
for democrats not because we're mean
about having a border so in your book
one of the things that you talk about at
length and i thought this was
fascinating cuz i had no idea about this
and i'm pretty up on these things is
that is the the complete lack of
government statistics when it comes to
illegal immigrant crime because you you
figured that should be a very easy thing
to look up and then in your book as you
detail it's almost impossible to find
any real government statistics on this
stuff
yes yes well this is this is a good one
of the advantages of doing my own
research that this book wasn't going to
be a book about immigration i had a
great idea for a book which by the way i
still think is a great idea for book and
i'd written a couple of chapters at
least drafted them and I get to my
immigration chapter and I go to look up
you know basic obvious facts how many
immigrants are in prison two weeks two
weeks of looking and I'm a fanatical
research or the Census Department the
Department of Justice the Bureau of
Prisons which has to be pretty good on
these things because they have to keep
the different different gangs separated
so they really need to know if they have
a reason to know I look in the New York
Times and Nexus and has anybody argued
about this and everybody's arguing about
wild guesses by the government they
refused to tell us and every time I come
across the government report that seemed
to be this is what I mean about the
first line for Anna Karenina they the
truth is always the same the lies are
lies in their own ways so you'd have to
you start reading their board I think
hallelujah here it is a report titled
you know immigrants how many immigrants
are in prison and then you start reading
the report and oh every year except
nineteen twenty five Hispanics are
counted as white
that's one report another one the GAO I
mean the Congressional investigators had
to ask the GAO to count to tell us
because the Department of Justice didn't
have it
the Bureau of Prisons didn't have it so
the GAO they've done a couple of massive
investigations but on closer examination
they're counting illegal and legal
immigrants which I think we should do in
the federal prison but in the much
larger state system they're counting
only illegal immigrants only illegal
immigrants for whom the states of
requested reimbursement only illegal
immigrants for whom the states have
requested reimbursement who have
committed at least one felony or two
misdemeanors you know we're not getting
anchor babies we're not getting the
children of of the one or the ones not
even the children but the ones that
amnestied by Reagan know I want to know
we're I think we have a right to know
and I think the last few weeks now that
thank you Donald Trump he's brought it
to the fore and the shooting in San
Francisco people are thinking yeah how
many are there incidentally I spent the
weekend and a lot of money looking up
these reports I don't know if you've
yeah I'm sure I'm sure you've seen some
of this liberals keep aggressively
asserting on TV while studies show
immigrants commit less crime than
Americans do now I know that's not true
what I don't know is how they're lying
so I wanted to know and I try to get the
reports well first of all you you ought
to be suspicious that one of the
arguments that are making is well New
York City has a lot of immigrants and I
don't see a lot of crime here that's not
[Laughter]
science it's [ __ ] and you know I was
making that argument being or although
is not a stupid man so the facts must
not be very good but anyway I tried
looking for the for the studies and I
put in sometimes you'd get a reference
to the name of a researcher and then I
was looking on Nexus to try to see what
where are these studies can I see what
they're saying and you'll get a
professor from such-and-such a
university well I just did a study and
it turns out first-generation immigrants
commit far less crime than Americans but
they're all hidden you outside trade
that I tracked down the study they're
all hidden behind paywalls and you know
I'm already paying for Scribd for Nexus
for
yeah a billion different services so
first I wasted two hours thinking come
on I couldn't you're not gonna make me
pay $50 for this crap a study but yeah I
had to keep paying $50 just so I could
skim down find out that the law is which
is what I'm probably going to tell you
all about in my column this week but
I'll tell you right now they are not
looking at Americans they are looking at
criminal Americans yep I mean they have
different ways of doing it but one guy
and the big headline and he's being
quoted in the Dallas Morning News in the
New York Times well my study showed
first-generation immigrants far less
crime than than that Americans the
native-born Americans so then you see
what he looked at he's looking at the
trajectory as he says so he had the the
base population were juvenile offenders
so this is someone who has already been
convicted of a crime which he admits
well my base my base study began with 45
percent blacks 33 percent Hispanics and
15 percent whites that's not a that's
not a cross-section of America that's a
cross-section of our criminal population
the other ones will you know pick a city
at random and look at the native-born
Americans versus immigrants
let's take Detroit wait I'm sorry do you
think I'm not going to point out that
the black underclass has a very high
crime rate because I'm gonna point it
out no I'm thinking we want immigrants
to have to not just beat the black crime
rates
I want them beating the Norwegian crime
rates I mean why should any time
skipping all past this all lies
I'm skipping past this to get to the
point why are any criminals coming in no
we have our own criminals but you don't
need more
because again the topic sentence on any
discussion about immigration it is a
government policy like any other it
ought to be used to benefit the people
here if you are bringing in a child
molester molester one drunk driver one
person who needs government services or
English language lessons that are going
to have to be paid for by the taxpayers
that is not helping the people already
here I mean these ones they keep talking
about you know the hard-working ones
that don't commit crimes and you know
they're working so hard and supporting
their family of four and sending half of
their $8 an hour salary home and you
know that's fantastic they're very
admirable but how does it help America
no it doesn't they're using schools and
services and hospitals and medical
service services and the housing aid and
they're sending we are immigrants to
America both legal and illegal are
sending twenty billion dollars back to
Mexico every year that's funding Carlos
Slim who saved the New York Times from
bankruptcy another chapter in my book
you know Carlos Slim makes money off of
immigration especially illegal
immigration to the United States twenty
billion dollars that is a cost of
immigration you will never be told about
twenty billion dollars being sucked out
of the American economy that is money
that will never be used to buy an
American American product to hire an
American worker to purchase an American
house or tip an American you know Buffs
boy no that is just being sucked out of
the American economy we ought to just
you know tax Americans I mean it takes a
circuitous route from American taxpayers
to the US government to the low-wage
immigrants who need the support from the
taxpayers that's why they can take those
low-wage jobs who you know lives in an
apartment with five other immigrants and
then sends it back to Chiapas his
grandmother who then buys Carlos Slim
products Carlos Slim owns 40 percent of
the companies on the Mexican Stock
Exchange so he needs that money in
Mexico they then buy a Carlos Slim
product and it goes into Carlos Slim's
pocket so why do why don't can we just
you know write a check to Carlos Slim so
for people who don't know and I
no until I read your book in the can you
tell the kind of the story of American
immigration because you referenced it
earlier obviously for me as a Jew that
means that my great-great grandparents
got here in 1907 I believe and and so
it's the easy thing is to buy into
illegal immigration bad legal
immigration good because my grandparents
and great-grandparents came legally can
you explain why that is no longer the
case why even legal immigration needs to
be curtailed yes and by the way your
people are great other than the way they
vote once you vote that way ain't my
people well it used to be as Ben and I'm
sure his grandparents are an example
pre-1970 immigrants were as any
immigration policy would require better
than us that's what we want we want
immigrants way better than us immigrants
pre-1970 were more educated made more
money bought more houses and 30% of them
went home just take that fact alone 30%
of them couldn't make it and went home
we looked out across the world and
skimmed the cream from the rest of the
world
unfortunately the 1965 act came at the
same time as the Great Society programs
when America was transferred transformed
into a massive welfare state well that
is obviously going to change not only
the sort of immigrant you're getting
well the 1965 act did that through a
series of complicated rules to bring in
people from his culture from cultures as
different from ours as possible and as
poor as possible because again they'll
work for the the work for the rich and
film vote Democrats nobody goes home why
would anybody go home go on welfare and
they are voting 8 to 2 for the Democrats
so what do we do about the h-1b visa
issue because you talk about this
because they're the one of the like Ted
Cruz is very good on immigration accepts
for according to you legal immigration
to h-1b visas h-1b visas are high-tech
visas for people who don't pay attention
to this stuff very closely so can you
explain the problem with the h-1b visa
process and why even that needs to be a
curtailed according your book yes yeah
a lot of Republicans get stuck on this
issue so I won't
I won't attack Ted Cruz for it because
so many people I mean I keep having to
I'm gonna have to get like a shot-caller
for Sean Hannity and a few other people
who interview me because they keep
talking about illegal immigration other
than the first chapter of my book where
I talk about amnesty because that just
ends the country overnight then it's
then it's lights out the rest of my book
is doesn't particularly distinguish the
Hmong immigrants up here in Fresno and
out in Minnesota engaging in massive
amounts of human smuggling child rape
credit card theft shooting hunters
because they don't understand private
property this is explained with great
sensitivity in the Minnesota papers no
they're all legal immigrants the Somalis
voting for Al Franken and then going
back to fight with Isis they're all
legal no we are talking about the legal
immigrants coming in and the h-1b visas
in particular the ones that most
Republicans have a soft spot for mostly
because we are lied to about oh there's
just some so high IQ they have such
gigantic brains isn't only the only time
I mention IQ in my book is to quote the
ones who want the cheap labor on the
aged oh they have such high IQs it's
just stunning
no h-1b visas are being used well in in
the worst cases to bring in concubines
for Bali ready locky ready one of our
model immigrants in San Francisco he
bought twelve-year-old girls from their
parents for sex brought them in on h-1b
visas one died this happened I don't
know it's in the book like 2001 2002
I followed the news very closely when I
came across this I called up my friends
many of whom also follow the news
closely and said hey did you hear about
this case in San Francisco an Indian
immigrant bringing in twelve-year-old
girls he had bought from their parents
for sex which any have sex with all of
them at once he also brought in his
Busboys he had a lot of restaurants and
real estate property that story was not
broken by the San Francisco Chronicle in
both the police and the media brushed it
under the rug it was broken by a high
school journalism class they had not yet
attended Columbia Journalism school and
did not know no it's against our
journalistic practice to report facts
that are unpleasant about our model
immigrants so he's bringing in you know
Busboys janitors and concubines under
the h-1b there's there's one category of
how it's an utter fraud utter other
category even the ones who are doing the
computer programming work well no
they're not the stars they're doing
standard computer programming work there
unfortunately you know Americans could
do the same work but they want to be
paid the way the h-1b visa works is it's
tied to a particular employer so if you
come in to work for Mark Zuckerberg and
then you know PayPal gives you a better
offer you can't leave without risking
losing your your visa so you're tied to
a particular employer it's it well it's
what's known in in the law as indentured
servitude which this country abolished a
hundred years ago
well now the rich are bringing it back
and you know we keep telling college
students oh you got a major in one of
the stem field science technology
engineering math well no the stem
graduates American stem grad it's half
of them are not employed in STEM fields
and there's their salaries haven't gone
up for a decade now why because Bill
Gates and Mark Zuckerberg are bringing
in the computer programmers that we can
do regular they just type away in their
little cubby holes for 12 hours collapse
go home and go to sleep it is just a
scam for the rich well on the free trade
side of that there could be a
counter-argument from the free trade
side which would be okay so if you don't
do that if you don't bring the
immigrants from there and they just
relocate to NZ on the outsource like
they've done to call centers for example
so what is the counter to the free trade
argument okay well I understand you're
worried about American wages but
American companies could just leave and
relocate in Hong Kong and hire everybody
there for cheap wages they could I don't
think they would we'll see but I've
the reason I even knew to look because I
kept reading about these high IQ high
it's mostly Indians writing about
Indians being the the Wonder the stars
of Silicon Valley so one thing Indians
don't have a problem with his
self-esteem but the reason I even knew
to Locke was because one of my friends
was runs a company was thinking of
relocating his call centers as probably
many of you have discovered to India and
he was the one who told me that India
has a very flat bell curve and that's
why I looked up what is the average
Indian IQ and no we by and large meet
the smart ones it's about the same as I
don't know like Panama the Sudan it
really isn't
this is just more low-wage work for for
the poor and as for the trade issue
particularly I don't know I think you
might want to get them here and it's not
worth the trouble of having them over
there and but to the extent that happens
I don't know okay so that's another
issue somebody else can deal with that
but I know Americans aren't getting the
jobs I mean 9 I I don't have a strong
position on free trade that's never been
my thing ok so as I think it becomes
kind of I'm suspicious because the same
people because it's the same people who
were so obsessed with all the who have
been lying to me for 20 years about
immigration who say we need we need
these trade deals like NAFTA so I I
never really thought the sin a qua non
of being a conservative was making sure
Mark Zuckerberg makes more money okay so
with regard to the media because you've
referenced it a few times one of the
criticisms that your book has gotten is
that there's so much anecdotal evidence
which is because as you stated it's
impossible to find statistics because
they don't exist but I did a little bit
of research on the on the shooting that
just happened up in San Francisco and
for the first two days of the shooting
the the shooter was referred to only by
his name of Texas Francisco Sanchez of
Texas yes and so I want you to talk a
little bit about how the media tends to
treat these stories when they originally
see them because it's amazing well
what's interesting about the San
Francisco case is that we did find out
by hook or crook
it was generally mentioned in the
articles about Texas man it generally
was at least mentioned he had already
been deported four times in my extensive
research I only found two other cases
I'm or two cases and now this one where
we found out very early on that the
illegal immigrant who killed an American
was an illegal immigrant though the
headline may still have been Texas man
the other one was the pleura Keyes
director who was driving in Pacific
Palisades with his 22 year old son and a
drunk illegal aliens were straight into
his lane smashed him killed him and his
son immediately of the illegal alien and
his passenger were fine and I thought
there are tools the LA Times was saying
it was an illegal alien and I you know
emailed some of my friends in Hollywood
and said what why why would this come
whoa and I don't know maybe it's just
they considered porkies such a
reprehensible movie that anyone who told
the director it doesn't reflect that
badly on the illegal but that wouldn't
came out and the other one happened a
year earlier it was an actress in the
inner of West Village apartment
Adrian Shelley and she was she was
murdered by an illegal alien and
immediately as soon as he was arrested a
week later immediately we all know and
the only thing that separates those
cases from most the cases I write about
is that they all happen in places where
liberals might be so I go back to my
point that you know know the rich are
perfectly willing to pay the costs of
bringing in peasant cultures that's
because they don't pay the costs no they
move they're their maids out to the
suburbs and they come in to clean the
house and then go back and and fill up
your schools and your hospitals and rape
your kids so in your book one of the one
of the big issues obviously that you
take on also aside from the sort of
media bias is is the fecklessness of the
GOP on this issue why do you think that
the GOP is pathologically incapable of
taking on this issue in any real way I
used to think it was cowardice I now
think it is pure stupid
your stupidity could be so many things
and actually if I could just get back to
one other thing the anecdotal examples
aren't to prove the point chapter seven
is where you'll see that was the chapter
written through tears of frustration and
rage of how I described I you know you
go looking for basic crime facts I mean
I think I do have some pretty good facts
that aren't anecdotal the US Marshall's
most-wanted list
take a look at that one New York state
prisons they they used to count because
again prisons really do have to know
they may not they may not publish it but
they do have to know the diff different
ethnic groups because they get into huge
gang brawls in the prisons and and so I
have a list of of where where people are
from from the New York prisons I think
that's pretty devastating the main way I
use the anecdotes isn't to prove the
point it's to attack the media it's it's
just mind-boggling how they hide I have
these you know sprinkled throughout the
book these fought the immigrant chapters
well I'll give you the mainstream media
article and you know my comments
throughout and you know you're
completely convinced that you know it's
some farm boys up in up in Fresno who
have who have gang rapes these little
fourteen-year-old girls and only when
you read the court transcripts three
years later oh my gosh they're all
longer why couldn't you tell us that the
San Francisco case I mentioned with
model immigrant volley ready lucky ready
that story was never mentioned in the
New York Times
never never never how much ink as the
New York Times spends on rapes that
didn't happen by the Duke lacrosse team
and UVA how much ink was wasted on
Ferguson where Big Mike did not put his
hands up and say hands up don't shoot
but actual cases of shocking heinous
gang rapes incest rape child rapes going
on in in American communities and for no
reason the media won't tell us about
this the Mexican gang rape case it's one
of the most hideous stories I've ever
read
again I called my friends who follow not
only the news but crime as much as I do
and they did not know about this case it
started I think before the in the
Clinton administration and during the
Bush administration and just the ugliest
most shocking gang rape of two little
girls in Texas led by an illegal alien
did a full Nexus search the case went on
for about a decade
never never was illegal immigrant
immigrants or Mexican mentioned in
relation to the main gang rapists and
this was the largest number of death
penalty cases in Texas which isn't shy
about the death penalty for about a half
century it was a pretty big case now
there was one article in The New York
Times about the case but never did our
media mention Mexican immigrant much
less illegal immigrant from Mexico until
they used the fact that the lead rapist
was a Mexican to try to spring him from
the death penalty that is the first time
ten years later and the full description
of the first mention I found was in a
Texas case that's how you're gonna
describe one of the most brutal gang
rapes I've ever read about so the point
of all the anecdotal evidence isn't to
prove the crime point it's to prove our
media is shockingly corrupt and lying to
you and you are going to have to demand
information about immigration if we're
ever going to get it and back to the
stupidity on the Republican know I mean
after the hear the fact that Trump has
struck such a chord do any of them have
eyes don't they want to win this is
apparently a popular topic I gave a
speech out in Ontario California last
week and I didn't meal I mean I you know
they're nice people like you and I'm
some of you might be Cruz supporters
Walker announced today if any of you are
Rubio supporters we'll have a little
chat about that but I mentioned in
during the question answer I meant
my fondness for Donald Trump in the room
exploded they were so happy it was 100%
for Trump I mean I can't say I believe
he's going to be the nominee if for
those of you who follow my work
assiduously you know that I'm constantly
saying Republicans don't get distracted
by someone who hasn't been a governor or
at least a senator it's not gonna be the
nominee I don't know with Trump if none
of these Republicans pick up on this
it's just wide open there and I wish I'm
you know my secret my secret plan and
this comes out in the last chapter of my
book the one god with a 20-year
fantastic record on immigration is Mitt
Romney and I was very disappointed when
he criticized Donald Trump my new hero
well when Romney comes in on the
hang-glider right into the middle of the
races the 17th candidate on that stage
and just bumps Rick Santorum off it'll
be me what I'm thinking people will see
that debate and think oh man Romney was
the best we ever had it maybe he could
take Trump as his vice presidential
nominee but look it I mean if it is Jeb
Bush or Rubio I'm not saying this in an
angry or threatening way you'd have to
vote for Rubio or rather for Hillary
over those two they are sole objective
is jab and Rubio their sole objective is
to open the border and pass an amnesty
at least with Hillary she wants to
socialize any other industries that have
been socialized ones that lose wars for
us abroad she wants to take your
children away make you no abortion
mandatory gay marriage mandatory perhaps
there are a lot of items on her agenda
where as Jeb and Rubio single-mindedly
focused on opening the border and
passing amnesty so if Trump isn't the
nominee I hope he does I mean if if it's
jabber Ruby I hope he does run as a
third-party candidate so there's
something so I can make it clear what my
vote is about in 2014 a lot of people
voted specifically about this topic and
this was the deciding topic
and I heard a very prominent member of
The Wall Street Journal editorial team
ashore an entire room at least twice
this size that that topic was not even
at issue in the 2014 election and the
the question is what do what should
Republicans have done what should they
do let's say that God forbid Hillary
Clinton wins or it's somebody else on
the Republican side who doesn't care
about this issue but there are people in
Congress let's say the Republicans hold
Congress what should they do right now
for example to stop Barack Obama's
executive amnesty that they didn't do at
the beginning of the year well they
shouldn't fund it there's that but first
of all let's let's just quickly take the
point what was the 2014 election and
about Tom cotton and Arkansas beat a
popular sitting Democratic senator by
running against him on Obama's executive
amnesty Ben Sasse in Nebraska took out a
field of candidates that I'm sure were
very popular with the wall street
journal' businessman who who think that
you know amnesty is a fine idea Ben
Sasse slapped both of me got more than
the two of them combined and of course
there was the famous election of Dave
brat in Virginia taking out for the
first time in history a member of the
leadership of Congress oh and I'd also
throw in here Scott Brown in
Massachusetts whom if we were you know
ranking races by level of difficulty you
know the rest of them are doing
somersaults compared to this guy who has
to do you know a triple layover flip off
the off the shallow end of the pool it
was Scott Brown came did incredibly well
by raising the amnesty issue it is
popular with voters it is not popular
with unfortunately the most of the
people who control the media and and
when that when the defunding of Obama's
executive amnesty came up the
Republicans did try to fight it and the
Democrats did filibuster up for three
weeks but unless you were reading
Breitbart you didn't know about it
there was just no media attention to it
and now I they've betrayed us on trade
my objection to the trade deal is it's a
backdoor amnesty it allows not only the
free movement of goods but the free
movement of people so so a company can
say well I need so many low-wage workers
coming in to take these jobs I
Republicans have a winning issue here if
they would just talk about it and look
the Ann Coulter rule is there there are
a lot of bad Republicans there are no
good Democrats there there are a fair
number of there of Republicans in both
the house in the Senate you were
fantastic on amnesty and we need to push
them and elevate them and people need to
be more like them and I also think we
should take out one this is what we as
voters can do they should stop being
stupid I think we only need to take out
one of these guys maybe John Boehner
just one of them
again as you know if you assiduously
follow my work I harangue to all of you
to vote for the Republican don't go for
the Tea Party candidate because really
bad things happen when Democrats control
the Congress by day I mean that's why
the brat thing was fantastic and and a
lot of these Tea Party candidates I'm
not even sure I believe half of them but
they're not that good they haven't run
for anything before we need to find a
place where there is a good candidate to
challenge a bad Republican and and that
as if Voltaire said in Candide we hang
one to encourage the others so now I'm
going to ask the apocalyptic question
which I know everybody every Republican
at this point has felt which is okay
what happens if we can't actually do
anything because it feels like on every
front the presidents of the United
States is doing whatever the hell he
wants there is no rule of law anymore
the Supreme Court obviously does not
care about the rule of law they're doing
whatever they please Congress is willing
to abdicate whatever authority it has
they're just handing over the cash so
what do citizens do and how fast is this
gonna turn very ugly that's a good
question I don't think it will turn any
uglier than it is I just feel like most
Americans are hunkered down hoping it
will all go away but it's not going to
go away and the winning path to follow
is Pete Wilson in 1994 and and look it's
it's Americans who have shut down three
amnesties in the last decade it wasn't
because you know some major network or
newspaper was alerting you to it the
American people would somehow by hook or
crook find out oh my gosh they're doing
it again they're trying to pass an
amnesty and now that three times now
shut down the Congressional switchboard
well yeah you may have to shut down your
newspaper switchboards or your TV
networks switchboards and make it clear
this is what we want to hear about
because this is all that matters in so
many ways and even to the Democrats I'd
say I mean I'm assuming this is roboking
audience that's why I talk about how it
is just
it's the end of the Republican Party
nationally we might have a few seats in
Montana Idaho and they're moving any of
the unaccompanied children there but but
I mean the whole country will be
California without the beautiful beaches
attractive people
you'll all be the Kardashians it'll be
awful but you there this is the even if
you are a Democrat this is going to
change our country in such a fundamental
way we will be like Brazil and I think
it'll just happen slowly and you'll wake
up one day and you know after election
after election that's funny I thought we
were gonna win that one we will have we
moment even be as good as Mexico because
Mexico has the advantage of living next
to the most wealthy country in the world
no we will be Brazil with a very very
wealthy 1020 percent and a very very
poor 80 or 90 percent it's it's it's
heartbreaking it's not only the freest
country that's ever existed but what
what always said America apart in
California I would say particularly was
our enormous prosperous middle class
enormous I always think that's why my
theory of why the ugly American image
developed in Europe because most of the
Europeans most the people you meet from
from foreign countries will you know fly
across an ocean to come to America we
only meet their elites no not not
Americans everybody used to travel to
Europe not now we're all worried about
paying rent holding on to your job
paying forward for all of those you know
special English translators at the
schools paying to support your Hospital
from going bankrupt I mean this is just
so crushing to the middle class but it's
good for Mark Zuckerberg it's good for
the rich it's good for the rich farmers
with all that cheap labor because they
refuse to mechanize so here we are in
California which is as you mentioned
sort of the bottom of the hill
what exactly are Californians supposed
to join at this question a lot because
we just for the first time passed we are
now a plurality Hispanic stay
and we are we are now minority white
state which means that I suppose that
pretty soon I kids can can apply for
affirmative action which is exciting the
first time I don't think it's gonna work
that way like this long it was gone
aside from using our lives to serve as a
warning for others what that's a good
question
wow this is not an encouraging pause I'm
thinking yeah I think it's you're just a
warning for others I don't see anything
else that can be done well I mean I
suppose I mean obviously alert the alert
the rest of us we're it's still time in
the rest of the states but also I wonder
I mean my prescriptions for the country
triple-layer fence I want it to be as
difficult to get into the United States
as it used to be to get out of East
Germany I'm so sick of hearing fences
don't work like shoelaces they just
don't work what are you talking about
course they were yeah well they cannot
come untied I know the human spirit my
long-term plan which would be fantastic
for Israel is to move them to the
northern portion of Mexico we have a
chapter why can't we have Israel's
policy on immigration that's a country
that knows how to defend its borders
that would be good for them good for us
fantastic for us they'd have us their
biggest best buddy in the whole world
right next to them on one whole one
whole side Obama's presidents are not
for long on that one we have to get rid
of the anchor baby policy I also think
we need to repeal
I want it I want it retroactively
incidentally in the news all now is this
El Chapo the biggest drug cartel leader
he's in my book he's married to an
anchor baby who a couple of years ago
flew back to California to give birth to
her own two anchor babies soon at your
expense
as soon as she had given birth to her
two anchor baby she flew right back to
join El Chapo who is who replaced I
think Osama bin Laden on Interpol and
the FBI's most wanted list and hmm how
did he escape from prison well because
in Mexico the cartels own the prisons
let forget California that's your future
America so as I described in my book is
the anchor baby policy was a footnote in
a Justice Brennan opinion in 1982 this
does not go back to you know the
Reconstruction Amendments the 14th
amendment was about one thing again
utterly insulting to black Americans the
14th amendment hmm why was that passed
so that some de la Rosa could usher
across Mexican women were eight and a
half months pregnant they could drop a
baby and say ha you didn't catch me I'm
an American citizen you know it but
people don't put trapdoors in a
Constitution a secret trapdoor who this
will surprise them to get an amendment
pass you need a mass feeling about a big
thing we had just fought a civil war to
force again the Democrats to stop
enslaving blacks that the 14th amendment
is absolutely exclusively about black
Americans that's what it's about and by
the way it's not about gay marriage
either but they're at least gay
Americans here we're talking about
people who've never set foot on US soil
before playing a game of Red Rover with
our Border Patrol for the most precious
possession in the universe citizenship
in this country no that is not how you
get American citizenship
but justice Brennan
this only came in 1982 1982 justice
brennan slipped it in a footnote of a
1982 opinion it is utterly outrageous
fraudulent justice rather Judge Richard
Posner whom as you can attest very smart
most cited federal judge not a friend of
social conservatives this isn't you know
me speaking a few years ago I quote him
in the book he concurred in an
immigration opinion for the sole purpose
of adding a concurrence that that said
Congress would you end this anger baby
policy it's not in the Constitution pass
a law tomorrow and end it it's not only
got to be ended but and this would save
California I want a retroactive
[Music]
I mean this what what if we had a
mentally delusional Supreme Court
justice not that hard to imagine who
says you know all of America or all of
the world is a citizen of America are we
all going to honor that because that's
what's happened with the anger baby
policy make sure Kennedy takes his drugs
this morning yes what if we had a I
guess that was so anchor baby policy the
wall
oh yeah the moratorium we need a
complete more immigration moratorium so
this isn't just about this isn't just
about Latin America
it isn't just throughout Mexico I don't
want European immigrants coming I don't
want anybody coming no marriage no no
refugees no asylees just shut it down
for ten years and you'll see I explained
it toward the end of my book my original
idea was let's go back to pre nineteen
seventy rules and try to get as I say
people are better than us that rather
than people who are worse than us but
that won't work because we have all
these nonprofits we have hundreds of you
know ACLU migrant rights groups and
George Soros Open Society Institute and
law Raza founded by the Ford Foundation
incidentally not by Hispanics like LULAC
was we have hundreds of these groups I
do a paragraph that goes on for a full
page of just some of them and those are
all the ones who become the immigration
judges those are all the ones who work
at the INF until they are all out of
business and vacationing in you know
Cuba and fighting with the the tupac
amaru in in peru until they are gone
America can't be safe so we need to just
shut down immigration altogether for a
decade dust off the books assimilate the
ones already here and then we can start
it up again totally cheap I can do it
all before breakfast
just send me the photos I'd be right 99%
of the time I'd be better than what
we're getting now 100% of the time
and Colter 11-time New York Times
bestselling author thank you so much
thank you
[Applause]